Putin und seine atomstreitkräfte der
russenpräsident schaut auf seine
bedrohlichsten Waffen und das ganze
übertragen natürlich im kreml-fernsehen
dieses Bild schickt Putin um die Welt
und es soll uns Angst machen mal wieder
natürlich wie dicht steht Putin
tatsächlich davor eine Atomwaffe
einzusetzen Putin der seit Tagen das
Gerücht streut die Ukraine selbst wolle
das eigene Gebiet mit einer solchen
Bombe verwüsten
Ebene Stunden
Mittwochnachmittag der krimml-diktator
höchstpersönlich ergreift das Wort
Wladimir Putin es zunächst gegen die USA
sie haben das ukrainische Territorium in
ein Übungsplatz für Experimente der
biologischen Kriegsführung verwandelt
jetzt Pumpen sie schwere Waffen rein
ohne einen einzigen Beleg für seine
These vorweisen zu können erklärt Putin
dann uns sind die Pläne bekannt zu
provokationszwecken eine schmutzige
Bombe einzusetzen das heißt der Russen
Anführer droht jetzt höchstpersönlich
eine Atombombe in der Ukraine zu zünden
und diesen gewaltigen Terroranschlag
anschließend Kiew in die Schuhe zu
schieben bemerkenswert ist jedoch nicht
nur die Tatsache dass Putin die würde
Theorie nun persönlich verbreitet
sondern auch Zeit und Ort an dem er das
tut denn Putin hält seine atomrede
während der Übung der strategischen
abschreckungskräfte der russischen Armee
sie halten am Boden zu Wasser und in der
Luft ein Training ab um den Ernstfall zu
proben einen Atomangriff auf Russland
bei dem Russland mit einem Nuklearschlag
antwortet das Putin den Ukrainern jetzt
persönlich vorwirft eine schmutzige
Bombe zünden zu wollen stellt eine
weitere Eskalation der russischen
lügenkampagne dar
also Putin der behauptet die Ukraine
bereite eine schmutzige Bombe vor um die
auf das eigene Gebiet abzuwerfen darüber
müssen wir reden mit unserem Bild
Militärexperten Julian Röpke hier im
Studio grüße Dich Julian jetzt haben die
Russen den Beweis sagen die Russen und
streuen über das
Verteidigungsministerium Fotos von
angeblichen Vorbereitungen einer
schmutzigen Bombe was sollen diese Fotos
zeigen und beweisen und was beweisen sie
wirklich ja ich muss leider wieder sagen
sie sind ich sag so oft lost in
Propaganda verloren in ihrer eigenen
Propaganda wir sehen dort dieses Foto
diese Fotos die gestern veröffentlicht
wurden vom Verteidigungsministerium
selbst auf Englisch auf Deutsch auf
Französisch um der Welt zu zeigen das
sind die Ukrainer sie bereiten ja
Atombomben vor schmutzige Bomben vor und
was ist es slowenien hat sich gestern
geäußert es ist ein Müll aus Slowenien
12 Jahre alter Müll und zwar Feuermelder
Feuermelder die vielleicht irgendwann
mal in einer atomeinrichtung
genutzt wurden und dann eben
abtransportiert wurden in einer in eine
Reinigung und dort eben in diese Tüten
reingepackt wurden das ist der einzige
das hat also nichts mit Atomen nichts
mit Ukraine und nichts mit 2022 zu tun
nennt ja auch immer wieder das Wort
schmutzige Bombe dann gibt es noch die
Atombombe was ist denn der Unterschied
klär uns mal auf also erstmal wieder
genau wie du sagst er bringt alles
durcheinander er sagt die wollen eine
schmutzige Bombe zünden dann sehen wir
eine Karte die zeigt aber genau eine
Explosion auf dem besetzte
Atomkraftwerken gleichzeitig erzählen
sie dann was von taktischen Bomben die
sie auch einsetzen könnten genau also es
gibt ein ganz großen Unterschied in der
taktische Atombombe ist tatsächlich
etwas was die Russen abschießen können
entweder von einem Flugzeug oder von
einer
Artilleriestellung wo eben eine kleine
Atombombe explodiert die das ist nicht
das was man sich unter dem ja nuklearen
Holocaust vielleicht vorstellt sondern
wirklich was was vielleicht ein
Fußballstadion komplett ausradieren
könnte aber außenrum geht es den Leuten
noch halbwegs gut die zweite Sache ist
die schmutzige Bombe eine schmutzige
Bombe ist ein regulärer Sprengsatz der
aber zum Beispiel mit Atommüll versehen
wird und abhängig davon wie viel Atome
oder spaltbares Material da drin ist ist
es so dass entweder nur die nur in
Anführungsstrichen die heute vielleicht
nach zwei Jahren Krebs kriegen oder aber
10.000 Menschen evakuiert werden müssen
weil es wirklich Strahlenkrankheiten
gibt das dritte wäre eine Möglichkeit
die auch immer wieder angesprochen wird
dass eben in diesem besetzten
Atomkraftwerk SAP Berisha es zu einer
Art Gau kommt das scheint auch Russland
nicht auszuschließen zumindest waren sie
immer wieder davor und das wäre
natürlich dann vergleichbar mit
Tschernobyl jetzt geht es natürlich in
diesem Krieg auch um Desinformationen um
Propaganda von allen Seiten und
Zuschauer werden möglicherweise sagen
woher weiß jetzt der Röpke dass der
Röpcke Recht hat also mit welchen
Informationen arbeitest du Julian
also wir schauen uns das natürlich an
wie es alle anderen tun wie alle anderen
gestern also Open Source nach
öffentlichen Quellen beispielsweise wenn
die slowo slowenische Regierung sagt das
ist unser das Foto können wir Ihnen
zeigen dass original das ist von 2010
und Sie können das zeigen ohne Aufdruck
ohne russischen Aufdruck dann können wir
sagen okay alles klar
höchstwahrscheinlich stimmt das wir auch
selbst können suchen
können im Internet zum Beispiel suchen
und sagen ist dieses Foto neu da gibt es
eine Rückwärtssuche und wir können sagen
okay das ist nicht von aktuell sondern
wesentlich älter das haben wir immer
wieder gesehen dass Russland uralte
Fotos benutzt wir versuchen so viele
Quellen wie möglich zu haben also ebenso
sogenanntes Cross checking das heißt wir
verifizieren immer eine Information mit
einer anderen Informationen fragen
jemanden nach ob das in Ordnung ist und
wenn sich dann am Ende herausstellt das
ist eben wie jetzt eine aus der Luft
gegriffene Lüge dann nennen wir das auch
so und Informationen werden eben von
allen Seiten überprüft von der
russischen wie von der ukrainischen
danke unseren bilderexperten Julian
danke dir
[Musik]